well no one we've just been seeing
scenes you know on your show here I know
this is going on in my constituency and
across the country no one wants to see
these strikes happening absolutely not
not the teachers not the kids themselves
but importantly nor do the teachers and
order the teachers they the government
has known that there were risks of
strikes since last summer
and the government at no point sat down
with the unions to try and look at
space for a compromise that could have
avoided these strikes now it's quite
staggering that in the times since then
we've had five different secretaries of
State for education you'd normally get
one and they would be in post for years
we've had five just in the last year a
revolving door of Chaos in the
department for Education the first of
those was Nadeem zahawi who we now know
was more focused on issuing legal
threats to journalists who are asking
legitimate questions about his tax
Affairs when he should have been
focusing on negotiating these strikes
well he wasn't doing the job he wasn't
doing the job he should have been doing
um a labor social state for Education
would have sat down with the trade
unions and sought to find a way through
this you can't get a compromise you
can't get a negotiation if you don't get
round the table so the very first thing
they should be doing they just had them
in the office twice in don't they but
she's refused to talk to them about pay
which makes it which makes it very
difficulturals which are also important
to teachers but she's come up with no
answers to any of those either now if
you look at what is the root cause of
what's Happening Here in the last decade
we've had the worst decade for wage
growth since the Great Depression of the
1930s Teachers Pay like many other
workers pay has gone down uh in real
terms we've now got inflation at
something near a 40-year high it's just
below the very highest it's been in 40
years and teachers are being offered a
real terms pay cut now these are the
people that were looking after our kids
during the pandemic they kept going to
work while many other people were not
going to work these are people who've
got the best interests of children at
heart it is incumbent on the government
to sit down and talk to these people but
really with all of these problems we're
seeing you know I I've had trouble
getting in today because the trains are
on strike the buses are on strike we've
seen the nurses strikes we've seen the
ambulance strikes this is a real Tory
winter of disc content but the root
cause of it is we've got a government
that has failed to grow the economy and
if you can't grow the economy you can't
give people the wage Rises they they
want to see 30 billion quid was it's
going to come from to pay all these
public sector workers well it can only
come from growing the economy you know
if there was a labor time well it does
take time but they've had 13 years now
they've had 13 years now and what we've
just seen the the IMF published some
figures yesterday the British economy is
shrinking when all the other economies
in the G7 major economies are growing
often wrong we're actually we're
actually growing slower than Russia and
Russia is subject to Major International
sanctions that's a projection the IMF is
often wrong they've had 13 years in
power now labor was in power for 13
years before that the economy grew twice
as fast under labor than is grown under
the conservatives we had the chairman of
Tesco's recently come out and say
there's only one player on the pitch
when it comes to economic growth and
that's the labor party with our green
Prosperity plan to invest in the the
good green jobs the new technologies of
the future if the government had focused
on growing the economy we wouldn't be in
the
messes that are being asked for you
would be paying all of them no no I'll
have to be clear about that because when
that election eventually comes if there
is a labor government elected on the
Thursday everything isn't sorted on the
Friday we will inherit a mess like
nothing that's been seen for a
generation and it will take time to fix
that what we would do is sit down with
our trade unions and talk about the
long-term prospects and there will be
hard proposals on the table one of them
is that we would end the tax break for
private education that will raise 1.7
billion pounds that we would look to
invest in six and a half thousand new
teachers to ease workloads in the
schools but also increase the number of
extracurricular activities that parents
want to see their their kids do that
really helps those kids develop as a
rounded uh individual further down the
line so a very different approach from a
labor government instead of that we've
got the tourism passing new laws this
week that are actually threatened to
threaten to sack teachers Sac nurses the
last thing we need is for them to make
this crisis worse and yet that's what
the government's doing talk to me about
Dominic Raab
um allegations by
um
people that work for him in double
digits who say that he is a bully that's
the allegation against him and at least
one of them said that they had Suicidal
Thoughts what should be happening while
that's being investigated well first off
like okay like you I've read those
reports and it's very hard to read isn't
it because nobody going into their place
of work should be subject to bullying
and intimidation that leaves them in a
situation like that and as you say there
are dozens of people now that have come
forward with um with allegations I think
this really now goes to a question of
the prime ministers uh he promised us
when he came in to Downing Street just a
few months ago integrity and
professionalism and accountability well
what did he know about these allegations
about Dominic Robb and why did he
appoint him and if he didn't know then
and he hasn't made that clear to us then
why on Earth is Dominic Robb still in
post today with this number of
allegations of that of this level of
severity the normal thing would be to
suspend somebody while they are fully in
investigated and yet Dominic Robb
remains in post if he really is the kind
of bully that these allegations are
claiming then he is still being let into
the ministry of Justice every day and he
is still able to carry out these actions
uh against junior members of his staff
senior members of his staff who are
finding it difficult to cope in the
interests of safety Rishi sunak should
suspend Dominic Robb while the
investigation goes ahead but I'm afraid
Rishi sunak is too weak to do that just
like he was too weak to sack suela
bravaman when she breached National
Security just like he was too weak to
get rid of Nadeem zahawi when these uh
exposes about his tax Affairs came out
Sunday he took weeks to do that we all
knew what was going on and the Prime
Minister was stood there shrugging his
shoulders and saying he didn't know well
the rest of the world seems to know he
say due process again isn't he is hiding
behind a cover because what you do in a
normal Shadow Justice secretary I mean
you know about Law and Order in this
country surely people are innocent until
proven guilty due process doesn't mean
that your if you suspend somebody it
doesn't mean that you know that they
have committed the offense it means that
the level of severity is so great that
you're removing them for the workplace
in the interest of the safety of
everybody else who works there the
investigation then goes ahead if he was
really relying on due process he would
actually suspend Dominique Rob he's not
he's too weak to do that we've seen it
again and again it would with the whole
number of scandals that have come uh
come out about various members of his
cabinet
he really wants to show he's committed
to Integrity he will suspend Dominic
Robb while these investigations go ahead
if Dominic Robb is then cleared well
then he can come back but if not Dominic
Rob would need to go are you really
worried about the Safety and Security of
the people that work with Dominic well
you just told me somebody felt suicidal
when things have got that bad and a
colleague gets well somebody said they
feel suicidal if it was just one person
on their own perhaps you could say you
know it's one word against another but
we know there are dozens of allegations
now and it's that level of severity that
means that the Prime Minister if he
really meant what he said about
integrity would act do you process I
know I've not always worked in politics
I used to work
in publishing people were suspended if
there were serious allegations about
them and if they were they're not proven
to be the case they would come back to
work but the interests of safety in the
ministry of Justice everybody has the
right everybody deserves to go to work
and feel safe and not bullied and not
intimidated the severity of the
allegations is so great miss Mr Rob
should be suspended thank you for
joining us on the program much
appreciated thank you thank you